[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
die zubereitung des tri lecce poetry
ledger ist ein milch kuchen der aus drei
leckeren schichten besteht
ursprünglich kommt der kuchen aus
albanien hat aber seinen weg durch die
ganze welt gefunden und das ist auch gut
so denn ich zeige euch heute den wohl
leckersten milch karamell kuchen der
welt
wir beginnen mit dem rührteig und
hierfür benötigen wir eier zucker mehl
backpulver und vanillezucker die genauen
mengenangaben schreibe ich euch wie
immer unten in die infobox wir starten
mit den eiern die geben wir zusammen mit
dem zucker und dem vanillezucker in
unsere rührschüssel und schlagen das
ganze fünf bis sechs minuten lang schön
hell cremig
[Musik]
selbstverständlich könnt ihr auch eure
handrührgerät verwenden dann müsst ihr
das ganze ein wenig länger schlagen
sobald die masse dann schön hell und
sehr cremig geworden ist geben wir die
restlichen zutaten mit hinzu
[Musik]
damit der teig schön locker wird und es
keine klümpchen entstehen siebe ich mehl
und backpulver zur sicherheit noch mal
und rühre dass ganz kurz unter bis sich
alles miteinander verbunden hat
[Musik]
das ganze dauert auch nur wenige
sekunden und dann hat sich der teig
verbunden und kann in unsere form
gegeben werden
die maße meine auflaufform schreibe ich
euch gerne unten in die infobox ihr
müsst nicht die gleichen maße nehmen
aber dann habt ihr noch ungefähre
vorstellung wie hoch ihr kuchen wird
[Musik]
nachdem dann alles noch mal schön glatt
gestrichen wurde geben wir den teig in
den vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad
ober und unterhitze für etwa 30 bis 35
minuten in die untere einschub leiste
die zwischenzeit nutzen wir für das
karamell und hierfür benötigen wir
zucker und creme fraiche den zucker
lassen wir in unserem kochtopf bei
mittlerer stufe langsam erhitzen und
wichtig ist dass ihr euch dabei zeit
lasst uns nicht die höchste stufe nimmt
ansonsten kann es passieren dass euer
karamell später bitter schmeckt in top
schwenke ich dabei immer wieder hin und
her damit sich auch alles schön verteilt
und der komplette zucker schmidt
anschließend geben wir die creme fraiche
mit dazu und dann wird das ganze erstmal
hart durch den temperaturunterschied im
müssten aber auch fleißig umrühren und
dann löst sich das ganze auch auf und
die klümpchen verschwinden
[Musik]
nach einigen minuten ist das karamell
auch schon fertig das gebe ich jetzt
noch mal in eine andere schüssel und
lasse das vollständig auskühlen
[Musik]
nun bereiten wir die milch tränke zu und
dafür benötigen wir sahne milch und
puderzucker alle drei zutaten werden
jetzt miteinander verrührt so lange bis
sich der puderzucker aufgelöst hat
[Musik]
die milch trinke kommt jetzt kurz an die
seite und es geht weiter mit unserem
frisch gebackenen kuchen den stechen wir
jetzt großzügig mit einem zahnstocher
ein so dass überall gleich die milch
tragen kommen kann
und der kuchen schön getränkt werden
kann wenn ihr dann soweit seit gibt ihr
die milch komplett über den kuchen und
es kann sein dass sich das anfangs ein
wenig viel vorkommen aber glaubt mir die
menge ist genau ausreichen macht auf
keinen fall weniger ran sonst kann es
sein dass der kuchen zu trocken wird
ich persönlich finde es am besten denn
der kuchen schön warm ist und die milch
trinke kalt dann funktioniert das für
mich am besten
nun müssen wir den kuchen bis zum
vollständigen auskühlen in den
kühlschrank geben
nun bereiten wir die leckere creme
schicht vor und hierfür benötigen wir
kalte schlagsahne außerdem kalte
mascarpone etwas sahne stand mittel und
vanille extrakt oder vanille zucker
für die zubereitung geben wir mascarpone
schlagsahne und vanille extrakt in eine
schüssel und rühren das so lange bis
sich alles miteinander verbindet
[Musik]
wer kein vanille extrakt oder vanille
zucker da hat der kann auch ansonsten
gerne ein teelöffel zucker verwenden
aber noch mehr würde ich das ganze nicht
süßen den später kommt ja noch die süße
karamell creme obendrauf
nachdem sich alles einigermaßen
miteinander verbunden hat geben wir das
sagen stand mittel mit hinzu und
schlagen das komplett steif für das
steif schlagen der creme ist es wie
gesagt ganz wichtig dass die zutaten
kalt sind und nicht erst ein paar
minuten lang auf zimmertemperatur stehen
wenn ihr darauf achtet dann könnt ihr
eigentlich nichts verkehrt machen die
krim ist damit auch schon fertig und wir
machen weiter mit dem schichten auf
unseren vollständig ausgefüllten und
super saftigen boden geben wir jetzt die
creme schicht und die wird einmal schön
glatt verstrichen und dann geht es schon
weiter mit dem karamell
[Musik]
unser karamell muss auch komplett
auskühlen denn ansonsten würde die sahne
creme darunter schmelzen
ihr seht auch nach dem auskühlen ist die
konsistenz schön fest geworden und
dennoch streichfähig und jetzt geben wir
es komplett auf die creme und
verstreichen das ebenfalls glatt
[Musik]
und somit ist unser tree ledger auch
schon fertig und kann sofort serviert
werden dieser kuchen es unfassbar saftig
und weich ihr müsst ihn unbedingt mal
ausprobieren um ihr feedback da lassen
denn ich bin sehr gespannt was ihr zu
meinem tree lecce rezept sagt
[Musik]
falls euch das rezept gefallen hat dann
freue ich mich natürlich sehr über euer
abo damit ihr auch keines meiner videos
mehr verpasst und ansonsten auch liebend
gern über fotos auf instagram mit dem
hashtag kikis kitchen
[Musik]
ansonsten danke ich euch fürs
einschalten und zusehen wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß beim nachbacken und sagt
bis zum nächsten mal auf dieses kitchen
[Musik]